in some ways it's the women that are
embracing the masculine archetype in
some ways that are being successful I
mean they're they're being
extraordinarily responsible and they're
feeling a lot of these positions quicker
than men can I mean there and they're
graduating and higher rates of college
and they're declaimed they're declining
motherhood are there at least suspending
it throughout the West which is you
could argue for either ways there's
reasons for that but I guess my question
is well I think that the expression of
the masculine spirit in women isn't
denigrated like women don't get accused
of contributing to the patriarchy even
when they take positions in society that
you would think are fully patriarchal no
and which is a strange thing so women
who go to law school and then and then
practice as corporate lawyers say aren't
subject to the same what would you call
it claim that their activity is
facilitating the decline of the planet
yes I guess because they're seen as well
they're because of their gender I
suppose they're seen as as as leaders of
the rebellion against the patriarchal
spirit even though structurally it boils
down to the same thing sure so that
masculine classically masculine
symbolically masculine yearning for
hierarchical productivity and
competition is rewarded in women but not
in men and which is also a very perverse
thing because it doesn't make any sense
actually makes sense through the post
modernist view which is they're just
undoing the oppressor ship of the man in
the last hundred fifty years so the ends
justify the means that's the way they
look at it whatever power women can take
from men is a good thing that's the way
they look at it well there's a funny
thing about that too that like I read
this in 12 rules for life I was looking
at some of the Peale research data I
don't remember the figures precisely but
over the last fifteen years the
percentage of women who young women who
claim that they would like to be married
in a permanent relationship has gone up
a substantial amount I don't remember
what it was a 50 percent approximately
springs to mind but a lot at the same
time it's declined almost the same
degree among young men and so what's
what's perverse about this this is
something I've talked to my daughter if
you're a bit about
is that I mean if you ask young women
what they want I don't know if they can
answer because I don't know if they know
if they're 19 or 20 because I think
their heads are so muddled by what
they've been told that they don't really
know that's cut my sense is that women
want the opportunity to develop their
career in whatever direction they see
fit and fair enough but they want an
intimate relationship and usually a
monogamous one that's permanent and they
want to have the opportunity to have
kids and what you see happening
inevitably and I believe this to be the
case I've watched very carefully as I've
as I've grown up and got older because
I've worked with women my whole life is
that women are less less compelled by
their career as they approach their 30s
and more compelled by the desire to have
a permanent relationship and found
biological - I would argue - well I mean
I think it's it's a biological necessity
because women have to have children
relatively young that's correct but it's
interesting to watch it
phenomenologically and even the women
that I've seen you've had very
high-powered careers
is that as they move into their
especially their early 30s they start to
realize that the career is a pretty
one-dimensional enterprise even if it's
a good career because even good careers
are still jobs and good careers are also
very hard jobs they're like 70 hour a
week job and they're full bore
commitment jobs and to figure out how to
have a career like that and to have a
life to have a family to have an
intimate relationship to have children
and then to also be able to take care of
them that's a very complex that's a very
complex job to manage and so what's
strange is I think what's strange is
that the very things that the radicals
are undermining like the monogamous
family are actually those things that
women most want especially as they
approach the disease and so this is a
catastrophe on both ends of the of the
gender distribution